[music]
[music] Hallelujah.
>> [music]
>> Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Hey
everybody.
I've called this lecture the new age
agenda, but it deals with actually more
than just the new age agenda. The field
is so vast you cannot really cover it by
breaking it up into little components.
So basically all we're doing is we're
creating puzzle pieces and putting them
together eventually to form the whole
picture of a total onslaught on Jesus
Christ as sole savior and also
particularly the divinity of Jesus
Christ.
Well, who is behind the new age
movement? Once again, sad to say, but
the same power seems to be everywhere.
Behind the scenes seems like a web, like
a spider's web covering every base. A
man attributed more than any other with
steering the new ma new age movement is
a man by the name of Tylard Shardin.
Now, who was Tail Desardin?
Well, you should guess it by now. A
Jesuit priest,
Tylard dreamed of humanity merging into
God and each realizing his own godhood
at the Omega points.
This belief has inspired many of today's
new age leaders. Everyone has a quote.
Every statement I make has a quote. I
never say anything.
In fact, Charardine is one of the most
frequently quoted writers by leading new
age occultists. So, the Jesuit movement
again working stealthfully behind the
scenes. Desardine himself wrote a
general convergence of religions upon a
universal Christ who satisfies them all.
You see how fascinating that seems to me
the only possible conversion of the
world and the only form in which a
religion of the future can be conceived.
So once again, if we're going to set up
a Luciferian system, and we saw that the
Jesuit organization
using Freemasonry
has lifted up Lucifer to godhood and
renegade or degraded Jesus Christ.
Once again, they're looking for a
universal Christ that satisfies them
all, but they do not want Jesus Christ
because that is exclusivity.
The secrets of the Gnostics. All these
new age writings are steeped innosticism
which remove Jesus as the focal point
and replace him with Lucifer or man as
the final deity.
You had the Ebionites, the Marchonites,
the Gnostics and the Thomasines. All of
them basically teaching that Jesus was
just a mere mortal and that we in a
sense are divine and the divinity of
Christ is only to be reckoned with in
the same terms as we are divine.
Behind the scenes, the Roman Catholic
Church is controlling occultism at every
single level. It even has specialized
bishops like these wandering bishops who
deal with the occult worlds.
This is a man by the name of Don Bosow
and he had a vision, a Roman Catholic
visionary. He had a vision in 1862
where he claimed that he saw the gospel
ship land between the two pillars of the
faith. In other words, anchoring the
gospel ship between the two pillars of
the faith. And the two pillars were
number one the larger pillar the
eukarist
which meant that Jesus Christ had been
sacrificed again and again and again and
again. actually the eukarist which
symbolizes the death on a daily basis
through the mass in fact on an hourly by
the minute basis as they have worked it
out ensures that Christ remains
crucified dead crucified dead crucified
dead it is the body of Christ actual
fact the Eucharist then is the ultimate
celebration of the victory of Lucifer
over Christ
and the second pillar which they claim
is smaller has on it Mary which simply
means that
Jesus has been replaced by another
mediator. So that is actually what this
vision means. Of course in Catholic
terms it means the acceptance of the
eukarist and Mary by the entire world.
Now we must remember that in occultism
Mary can be both male and female. So
whether you put a female deity there,
Mary, Isis, Asterret, whoever you want
to put there, or whether you put the
male equivalent makes no difference
because he's androgenic. So you could
put Apollo there, the face of Apollo,
you could put Osiris there, you could
any one of them. It would be exactly the
same thing because Blavadsky says
they're one and the same.
Genesis 3:1-6. Now the serpent was more
cunning than any beast of the field
which the Lord God had made. And he said
to the woman, "Is it so that God has
said, you shall not eat of every tree of
the garden?" And the woman said to the
serpent, "We may eat of the fruit fruit
of the tree of the garden, but of the
fruit of the tree which is in the middle
of the garden, God has said, you shall
not eat of it, neither shall you touch
it, lest you die."
And the serpent said to the woman, "You
shall not surely die. For God knows that
in the day you eat of it, then your eyes
shall be opened and you shall be as
gods, knowing good and evil. That was
the original battle in Eden. Question.
God had said you will surely die. The
serpent had said you will surely not
die.
One of them is lying. Correct. One of
them is lying. If you are surely dead,
then you are a created being and
certainly not God.
And here the serpent says, in fact, if
you eat of it, you'll realize that you
are actually gods.
Another lie. These are the twin lies of
Eden told by the serpent. Of course,
Freemasonry teaches that it was the
other way around. That it was the devil,
as we saw, who told the truth and that
Yave, he's the liar. That's what we saw
in all those Freemason quotes. So, they
turn it upside down. This is therefore
central Jesuit teaching because the
Jesuits actually form masonry.
And when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food, there's the old appetite
problem coming in. And that it was
pleasing to the eyes
and a tree to be desired to make wise.
That was the big problem there. She took
of the fruit and ate. She also gave to
her husband with her and he ate.
Good. That was the battle in Eden. If
that was the beginning,
then the end will be the same. The same
victory that the serpent got in the
beginning, he will try to claim at the
end as well.
So, starting with Mary Baker Eddie,
there she is, the founder of the
Christian Science Movement, we're
starting to get organizations which give
themselves Christian labels, but which
teach everything which is not Christian.
This is a very clever move. Not
everybody is duped by it, but because
the name Christian is associated with
it, that means it must at least have
Christian values. Right? Wrong.
She writes in science and health with
keys to the scriptures, which was voted
one of the 75 books by women whose words
have changed the world by the USA's
Women's National Book Association. So
this is very influential work. One of
the 75 books written by women to change
the world. Amazing. Now what did Mary
Baker Eddie have to say? Here are some
statements. Science and health with key
to the scriptures which this religious
movement uses as a document in addition
to the Bible.
Evil has no reality. It is neither
person, place, nor thing but simply a
belief, an illusion of material sense.
page 71.
Well, I always ask myself the question,
what planet did she live on? Surely not
this one.
Jesus, the highest human corporal
concept of the divine idea,
rebuking and destroying error, and
bringing to light man's immortality.
Page 589.
Okay, so Jesus is just an example to
show us that we are immortal. But didn't
God say you will surely die?
Didn't he say that? Yes, he did. But she
says, "No, man is immortal."
Let us remember that harmonious and
immortal man has existed forever. Page
302. The Bible says he's a created being
man.
But she says, "No, he's immortal. He has
existed forever."
Death, it's an illusion. The lie of life
in matter, any material evidence of
death is false, for it contradicts the
spiritual fact of being. Page 584. Okay,
there is no death. Who said you will
surely not die?
The serpent said so. The soul is the
divine principle of man and never sins.
Hence, the immortality of the soul. Oh,
that's a very fascinating doctrine. So,
we are two entities. a shell that dies,
a soul that is immortal and that inner
being never sins.
You know that is a gnostic teaching
which uh the niclatians also liked which
the Bible says God hates that this body
is a shell so therefore what you do in
the body doesn't really matter. You can
eat whatever you like, you can stuff
yourself, you can fornicate. You can do
whatever you like. Who cares? you're
going to just drop the shell and carry
on im immortally.
God said it is given for man once to die
and thereafter the judgment. That's a
totally different story. So this is
definitely not biblical and it sounds
very much like serpent language.
She writes, "Man and women as
coexistent, eternal with God, forever
reflecting in glorified equality the
infinite father, mother God." That's an
androgenic God we have here. And this
sounds more like Lucifer than it sounds
like God. And this father God concept is
not biblical. Otherwise, it would have
said, "Our parent who art in heaven,
hallowed be thy name." But it doesn't,
does it? No. It says, "Our Father who
art in heaven." So, there's the one
movement that gives itself a Christian
name. Here's another movement that gives
itself a Christian name. The Mormon
movement. The Mormons call themselves
the Latter-day Saints of Jesus Christ.
So this is Jesus Christ's name being
used again and the information comes
from this angel over there who is the
angel Moroni.
I don't want to make a pun with that
name.
Anyway, here he stands on top of the
globe blowing his trumpet. Here is a
typical Mormon church. It has no windows
just like Masonic lodges don't have any
windows.
And the founder of the Mormon movement
is none other than Joseph Smith. And
Joseph Smith was a 33 degree Freemason.
What does that tell you? Who was his
god? If he was a 33 Freem degree
Freemason, then his god was Lucifer.
Now
this is his follower. is uh the next
prophet if you like the Mormon leader
Brigham Young who followed up Jo Joseph
Smith and he happened to be a 33 degree
Freemason
well let's check this out the church of
Jesus Christ of latter-day saints
Mormonism its founder Joseph Smith was a
high level Freemason his successor
Brigham Young was also another high
Freemason
according to the book black robe Brigham
Young was an intimate friend friend of
Peter Dmmet met one of the most powerful
American Jesuits of the 19th century.
Oh, we find them everywhere.
But they're never in the front row.
They're always in the back row so that
they never get bonked. The others get
bonked. Well, here Joseph receives from
the angel Moroni the gold tablets with
this new doctrine on it. Now, let's ask
him himself whether what I'm saying is
correct. So it's always good to go to
his own writings, his history of the
church.
In the evening, I received the first
degree in Freemasonry in the Nauvoo
Lodge, assembled in my general business
office. I was with the Masonic lodge and
rose to the sublime degree. There you
have it. Straight from the horse's
mouth, it cannot be denied. Mormonism
was started by Freemasonry under the
control of who? The Jesuits. Yes. Now,
what would be their principal
move to start an organization that
controls one whole state at least in the
United States and together with
Freemasonry controls the entire space
program because anybody who's ever been
in space is either a Freemason
or he is a Mormon. One of the two.
Very interesting. Not only that, they
are the organization which have the
greatest database on anyone ever living.
They will find out everything from who
you are, who your parents are, where you
lived, what you did, every single thing
about you. They have the database. This
is a database that will be important one
day when it comes to buying and selling
and who's going to get what in the new
dispensation. So they perform a very
important work for the Jesuit order. If
you look at Mormonism, they have the
same sort of ritual as Freemasonry. They
have their aprons. The handshakes are a
little bit different as you see. They
have their secret handshakes and all the
paraphernalia that goes along with it.
And this is their main temple at Salt
Lake City.
Again, you can see it's a pretty shut up
place. And uh when you go and look
there, you'll see the allseeing eye with
the Masonic handshake in it. You'll see
the moon and the Balhad symbol and the
sun and the upside down pentagrams.
former witch, mason, Mormon and Satanist
Bill Schneerbolan emphasized that to the
magician the inverted pentagram has one
use only and that is to call up the
power of Satan and bring the kingdom of
the devil into manifestation on earth.
So here is the symbol right on the
Masonic temple. I took these pictures
myself so I know they're there.
Uh, another quote, "You will find the
satanic pentagram invaluable and
indispensable if you attempt to attempt
to draw from the infernal power of our
Lord Satan. This extremely powerful
amulet is the sign of the microcosm and
is the summation of all occult forces.
In other words, there is no amulet or
talisman more powerful or even close to
as powerful as the satanic pentagram."
It's interesting that it's on virtually
every flag in the world, which is just
another story. So, if we look at uh the
Mormon temple, we will find them in
their upside down form relatively
frequently. All these symbols are all
over the Mormon temple. The allseeing
eye over there, down there, symbols of
the sun. They have circles. Originally,
they even had the dot in the middle, but
they've become a little bit more um
clandestine and have removed those uh on
their other churches. At the same site,
you will find the Star of David. All of
these features are in Mormonism. Here,
the restoration of the ironic
priesthood.
They claim that they have the priesthood
of Aaron. Now by the way that is a
blasphemy
because who has become the high priest
forever?
>> Jesus.
This means they are taking upon
themselves something that belongs to
someone else. They are robbing Jesus
Christ of his role and his authority.
Kathy Burns Masonic and Occult Symbols
illustrated says both masonry and
Mormonism refer to the Melkisedcic
priesthood.
In Scottish right masonry the 19th
degree is called the Grand Pontiff. It
is during this ceremony that the
candidate is anointed with oil made and
proclaimed a priest forever according to
the order of Melkisedc. I thought there
was only one who was of that order
today. Isn't that so? So both of them,
Mormonism and Freemasonry do this.
Hebrews 5:59 tells us, however, that
Christ glorified not himself to be made
a high priest, but was called of God, a
high priest after the order of
Malchisedc. But our cultists, Mormons,
Masons glorify themselves, and take on
themselves the honor of priesthood that
was given to Christ alone.
So when we titled the Siri total
onslaught, you can see that every aspect
of the world out there is designed to
rob Jesus of his power and his
priesthood.
This is the
choir room, if you like, of the Mormon
tabernacle.
This is where the Mormon choir sings.
And who has not been moved by this
choir? It is the most magnificent
music that you can imagine. And they are
world famous for their music.
But if you realize that in Satanism, you
can call him Christ too because Jesus
means Joshua. Joshua means Yave the
Savior. and Lucifer claims the same
title. So you can sing these beautiful
songs to another spirit depending on
whom you are obeying.
So many of these poor Mormons of course
have no idea because again in Mormonism
there are degrees and you get initiated
into higher and higher levels. So the
lower levels know absolutely nothing.
these poor little nun girls that walk
around there showing the people around
saying these wonderful things that they
have read and not realizing what they're
even saying.
If you look here at the Mormon uh
structures there, I mean, wow, it is
impressive. Money was obviously not an
object.
What about Mormon doctrine? Let's have a
look at that quickly. Section 27,
Doctrine of Covenants, verse 11.
Mormons. Mormons teach that Adam was
God.
Journal of Discourses, volume four. This
is their official writing.
That some sins are atoned for by own
blood only. What does that tell you?
Well, that's not biblical. The Book of
Mormon, Alma 7:10, says Jesus was born
in Jerusalem. That's not biblical. It's
minor, but it's just irritating. Journal
of Discourses, Volume 2, page 81, says
Christ was married to Mary, Martha, and
others.
Oh, that'll give you a good reason to
have a little bit of um, you know, more
than one wife. Why not?
They deny the atonement. We're going
through the same ritual again. One of
the most penicious doctrines ever
advocated by man is the doctrine of
justification by faith alone which has
entered into the hearts of millions
since the days of the so-called
reformation. Joseph Fielding Smith is
Joseph Smith himself writing the
restoration of all things page 192.
Well, doesn't that sound similar to what
West Cotton Hort had to say? Yes or no?
Well, this is Masonic teaching and
Mormonism is nothing other than a front
for freemasonry
masquerading as a religion of Jesus
Christ. The Mormon book in two nifty
222-2
says, "Adam fell that men might be and
men are that they might have joy." So,
Adam fell so that men may have joy.
That's interesting. Actually, this is
part of a sex cult. It gets kind of
perverse once you go into the details.
And I wouldn't even want to discuss
what happens in some higher echelons.
Let's not even go there. The fact of the
matter is enough to say that if a Mormon
dies, he has a lot of vestal virgins up
there to keep him occupied on the other
side. and their deity is married to
literally thousands and thousands and
millions of female spirit beings and
does nothing but fornicate from morning
till night to produce the souls that are
to enter into men to create men. It's
pretty disgusting doctrine really in the
secret regions.
Sterling W. Sil member of the first
quorum of 70 stated in the church
section of desert news July 3165 under
Christ Adam yet stands as head fell but
he fell in the right direction he fell
towards the goal Adam fell but he fell
upward Jesus says to us come up higher
huh so this is typically serpent
language when you fall you will gather
what wisdom you will become like God you
will go up not down. Brigham Young says,
"The devil told the truth about Godhead.
I do not blame mother Eve. I would not
have her miseing the forbidden fruit for
anything. Through the gift of sin,
humanity can achieve godhood." Well,
who's this speaking? Is this the devil
speaking or is this Jesus Christ
speaking? This isn't that doctrine of
covenants. Ye were also in the beginning
with the father. Man was also in the
beginning with God. intelligence or
light or truth was not created or man,
neither indeed can be. Again, you have
it there. Mormonism is nothing other
than Freemasonry masquerading as a
religion of Jesus Christ, deceiving
millions in the process and just being a
tool for the Jesuit order.
The Catholic Mass basically says the
same. Oh, blessed fault which does
procure such a redeemer. This is the
figure of Christ that they have at the
Mormon temple. And uh whether Jesus
looked like that or not, who knows? The
devil says he wants to impersonate
Jesus. So maybe Jesus looked like that.
I don't know. I'll find out one day when
he comes with the clouds of heaven. I
wonder whether he did have a split
beard, which is a symbol of a goat. But
nevertheless,
here we have
the leader, Joseph Smith. And if you
look at uh the figures over here, you'll
see a beehive.
And uh if you go and look in the book
two Babylons, you'll see that the
beehive is a symbol of paganism. This is
pagan deities. Now, this is a rather
fascinating story.
You see the world is being controlled by
occultists
and occultists often run in families. So
you have occult families which control
the world. Now some people go too far
and they say you know there's a
reptilian connection and there reptile
families and have you heard of those
stories before? Now let's not go there.
Let's just say is it possible that there
are families that control the world and
uh they come from royal families. Now
some royal lines have been eradicated,
eliminated, destroyed, wiped off the
face of the earth through Jesuit
intrigue and others have been placed in
power like the house of Stewart for
example in England. Every one of them
high masons those are all occultists. I
mean the queen is the queen of the
bilderberers. How much more occult can
you become than that?
So here you have these royal families.
Is it possible that these royal families
are controlling much of the world and
that the kings of the world will one day
rule? Well, let's just have a look at
something interesting. Here is the
Howland family chart which is published
at the Mormon temple and tells us who's
who in the zoo and who's related to this
family. One family. So, we're looking at
great great grandpa. Let's have a look
who his descendants are. One family.
You can check this out for yourself.
Joseph Ira Earl, very prominent man in
his old days. Joseph Smith. There's the
founder of the Mormon movement. He is
part of that family. He comes from the
same greatgrandfather.
Emma Hail comes from that family.
Winston Churchill.
He has the same great great great
grandfather.
Franklin D. Russerfelt has the same
great great grandfather. Uh, Richard
Nixon has the same great great
grandfather.
Do you mean to tell me that President
Ford had the same great great
grandfather? Do you mean to tell me that
George W. Bush Senior had the same great
great grandfather? George W. Bush Jr.
had the same great great
greatgrandfather.
Now, this is kind of strange. Do you
really believe that though they come
from different sides of the of the
earth's divide that they all come from
the same family? Do you think this is
pure chance? I leave it to your
speculation. I don't want to go further
into this. I just find it fascinating
that they all come from the same family.
From Churchill to how many presidents in
the United States? One, two, three, the
one in between four, five presidents in
the United States plus those from the
other side, plus the founder of the
Mormon movement, all from the same
family. It's very weird. Very weird. And
then if you go into Mormons and NASA,
you will find that all the top men, they
were all Mormons or they were
um masons. If you go into a Mason
temple, you will find the photographs of
the presidents and you will find the
photographs of all the great stars that
went up into the sky. Here is the
Scottish Wright Supreme Council Northern
Masonic Jurisdiction calendar, their own
calendar from 1998.
And it tells you some few interesting
things. Anybody recognize that one?
Buzz Aldrin. Anybody recognize that one?
Colonel John Glenn. And they tell us
what they were. 33 degree Freemasons. So
the lists are just endless. We've
already discussed that every single
president just about has been a
Freemason and you'll find them in the
Masonic presidential lists. So
Freemasonry
is also behind the new age movement.
Here you have their original magazine,
Freemason magazine, which was called The
New Age, but because they linked it too
much to Freemasonry, they changed the
name to uh Scottish rights.
Now, so many people have said to me that
I surely do not have the books I'm
talking about. I'm pulling it out of my
thumb. So, I took the trouble to put
them down on the white carpet and to
photograph them. There is um Pike's
book, Morals and Dogma. There is
Blavadski's book, Secret Doctrine.
Secret Doctrine, New Encyclopedia of
Freemasonry. A whole host of them. Now,
people tell me I just photographed them
from somewhere else and I'll put them on
the carpet. So, next time we'll
photograph them. I'll put them in my
teeth and in my hands and between my
toes. I'll do whatever it takes. I
really have these books.
Here is Alice A. Bailey the high
priestess and prophetess of the new age
movement. Remember that she received
messages from the Tibetan dwell. We
introduced her when we spoke about
freemasonry.
Leviticus 19:31 says, "Do not turn to
mediums and spiritists. Do not seek them
out to be defiled by them. I am the Lord
your God.
And as it is appointed unto men once to
die, but after this the judgment."
Hebrews 9:17. Let's just get these
voices and these verses clear. When
these voices come, are they contrary to
the verse? Probably yes. This woman has
written more books than most other women
in the last two centuries.
One of the most prolific writers of all
times, Alice A. Bailey. Her books were
published under the symbol of the lotus
flower and they were published by the
publishing company Lucifer Publishing
Company which caused such a stir that
they changed it to Lucus Trust. Now
there's only one other woman
that has written as much in our century.
Did you know that? Or in the last two
centuries there are only two women who
even
can compete on this issue. The one is
Alice A. Bailey and the other one I will
introduce to you in another lecture. So
contemplate that a nice row of books and
remember there's another writer who
wrote probably more even than this
one of the books problems of humanity
with the Masonic signs on it.
Reappearance of the Christ. This is a
preparation for the coming of Christ.
Forgetting the things that lie behind, I
will strive towards my higher spiritual
possibilities. I dedicate myself and you
to the service of the coming one and
will do all I can to prepare men's minds
and hearts for that event. I have no
other life intention. This is Alice A
Bailey writing. Now, this coming one is
not Jesus Christ because she's a
Luciferian. Who is she saying is going
to come? Lucifer, but they call him the
Christ. Now, which other movement is
waiting for the Christ to come? The
Mormon movement, right? They're saying
he will come and he will present himself
in their temple there in Salt Lake City.
Here's another movement that might
interest you, the Jehovah's Witnesses.
And there are millions and millions of
Jehovah's Witnesses in the world today.
Now the Jehovah's Witnesses were formed
by CT Russell who lived between 1852
1916. He's the founder of the Jehovah's
Witnesses. They vehemently deny any
Masonic connections. But this man was a
33 degree Freemason.
It's getting kind of boring by now,
isn't it? Getting kind of boring. Well,
let's have a look and see what we can
dig up. The divine plan of the aegis,
the helping hand for Bible students.
Here it is in the Norwegian language.
Notice the symbol that they use on the
front is the symbol of the god Rah, the
sun god Rah, the equivalent of the god
Shamash.
Here is an original
uh watchtowwer from December 1, 1916.
This is no longer deniable. There it is.
I photographed it myself.
And there it is, the symbol that
Freemasonry uses. There's the Masonic
symbol on it. And then he describes here
how um the founder Russell died. Here's
a perfect description by his companion.
He it was then that he stood again and
said, "Please make me a Roman toga. Make
me a Roman toga." He was dying and he
made him a Roman Togo from a sheet that
he put in him. I did not understand what
he meant but did not like to have him
repeat because he was so weak. His voice
had become so weak that he had to repeat
nearly everything. Dear brother Russell,
I do not like to ask you to repeat
anything, etc., etc. I said, "Brother
Russell, I do not understand what you
mean. I will show you. And then he took
this sheet and he took it around him and
etc etc. Fastened them together here.
This is how a highmason wants to die
when he gets to the point of death. So
the entire masonic ritual the high
masonic ritual of death is here
described. So Russell was a high
freemason a 33 degree Freemason whether
we like it or whether we don't. So this
is an occult society pretending to
represent
Jehovah Y.
If you look at his grave, you will see
that it also had the Masonic symbol in
the wreath on it. And the early
watchtowers also used this symbolism.
There it is. And there it is. You'll
find it on the early watchtowers. you
need to have very old ones. I got this
information from a Jehovah's Witness who
turned from Jehovah's Witness uh in his
old age. So if we look at the the
teachings of Jehovah's Witnesses, they
are the organizations that have made
more predictions of prophecy than any
other. And every single one of their
prophets, this is the chart of the ages.
Every single one of them has turned up
zero. For example, 1874 they said was
the coming of Christ. They never came.
1878 the resurrection they then taught
that had take place but were invisible.
1881 close of favor to the Gentiles.
Probation closed. 1914 Armageddon didn't
come. 1915 Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob
were to be resurrected. They were not
resurrected. 1918 Christianom and its
churches would be destroyed. Didn't
happen. 1920 the republics uh did not
disappear as they had said. 1925 the
establishment of the kingdom. Well, if
this is the kingdom, they can have it.
After 1925,
people would be able to call up Abraham
who would live in Jerusalem and have
their loved ones resurrected.
Nothing of that happened. The New World
Bible came out in 1950. Before that,
they just crossed out the King James
Bible, 1975, the end of the world. But
it did not come. Not one single
prediction. One of the things that the
Bible says about a prophet, a true
prophet, is if his predictions do not
come true, then forget about it.
End of the Gentile times. Page 99.
Jehovah's Witnesses. Concerning the
times of the Gentiles, we consider it an
established truth that the final end of
the kingdoms of the world and of the
full establishment of the kingdom of God
will be accomplished by the end of AD
1914.
Nothing happened. Sometime before the
end of AD 1914, the last member of the
body of Christ will be glorified. Did it
happen? No. Otherwise, how can they
still make Jehovah's Witnesses today?
It would be a kind of a waste of time,
right?
End of Gentile times page 77.
Now one of the features of occult
organizations that pretend to be
something else is that they use
subliminals.
Subliminals is something that you hide
within a picture to show that you really
are demonic or not. They use it in
movies. They use it in soundtracks. They
use it in all kinds of stuff. It's an
occult way of doing things. And normally
they do things upside down and all kinds
of interesting things. So if you go to
the old watchtowers and you have a look
at them, you will often find demonic
faces or uh masonic rituals hidden in
the pictures. So for example, this angel
on the land and the sea representing
Christ, he has these folds in the hand.
If you look carefully, you'll see it's a
demonic face. The raising up of this
young man is the same handshake that is
used to raise up Hyram Abif in the
Masonic ritual.
It's uh the lion's grip if you like. So
that is Masonic. And you'll also notice
that the finger was offset to one side
in that picture. And we'll see this
relatively frequently. If you look at
this rather unassuming picture in the
watchtowwer over here and you take a
little bit of a closer look, you'll see
that in the knot of the tree, you have
the head of the goat. There are the
horns, there are the eyes, there's the
skull. So, you have the symbol of the
goat hanging over them. If you look at
this man over here, he looks pretty
innocuous. If you turn him upside down
and you look carefully, you'll see the
demonic face in his hair. Now you might
think this is chance. Well, let's
continue here. The the angel over here
again with the offset finger. The keys
they are using is the Roman key. And you
will find many S's in their garbs and in
their closes, symbols of Lucifer.
And this picture is so full of Masonic
symbolism. It's just not true. Uh the
angel over here has hosts of Masonic
symbols in it. And over here you have a
subliminal. I don't know whether you can
see the subliminal. Can you see the
subliminal in the woman's dress? You see
something over there that's doesn't look
quite right.
>> All right, let's make it a little bit
bigger. Let's see what we can come up
with. Take a careful look. You really
have to look well. A subliminal is not
something that you're supposed to see.
And another thing about a subliminal,
some see it instantly and others don't.
This is a face of a man. Can you see it?
>> All right. Some can see it clearly.
There's a nose. There's the mustache.
There's a this. And the hair seems kind
of strange. Now, who is that? Is that
just any face or is it someone in
particular? Let me give you a a face on
the right.
Do you recognize him?
Do you recognize there's the beard?
There's the nose. There's the hair. That
is this individual over here. Who's he?
That's Zeus.
So they put all the subliminals in it
and some people will see it in. Who can
see it? Let me see. There are lots that
see it. Okay, great. Some just cannot
see it. That's the nature of a
subliminal. Now if we go to the other
one,
you will see over there masonic
triangles. You will see uh over there
you'll see pentagrams. All kinds of
things hidden. And then they will use
shadows and do it so cleverly. This is
supposedly Jesus. Of course, they give
Jesus here a different look to the
Mormons. They give him short hair. Uh,
notice that his foot is a goat's foot as
a shadow.
So, these are subliminals that they use.
Again, here, if you look at the garbs,
you can see the S's and the folds. All
kinds of things that they use. So this
religion again a religion started by
Freemasonry because the the idea is the
more distractions you have the more
likely you are to cover all the bases.
Doesn't that make sense? And what is the
aim of all these religions?
To remove the deity of Jesus Christ.
That's the aim of all these religions.
They teach, for example, the Jehovah's
Witnesses that Jesus is not God. He's
just a created being. Mormonism teaches
that. Freemasonry teaches that. The
occult world teaches that. Islam teaches
that. Insider Catholicism teaches that.
They all teach that. Somebody hates
Jesus Christ. Can you guess who it is?
>> It was Lucifer. Yes, it was Lucifer. and
his agent, the Bible says, is the
papacy. And they're going to use the
papacy to achieve its ends.
And I think it is high time that the
world is shown
the nature and the magnitude of the
total onslaught
against Jesus Christ as Lord, Savior and
only Savior on this planet.
We have seen that part of the new age
agenda
is to create as many organizations as
possible that deny the divinity of
Christ. Now, if you're going to cover
all bases, you also have to reach those
people who are not easily churched.
This organization over here is the
Bahigh organization, Hifa Israel. June
2003, nearly one and a half million
people have visited the garden terrace
surrounding the shrine of the Barb on
Mount Carmel. The Barb, this is where he
lives
or where he is represented. He doesn't
live there, of course, anymore. since
they were first open to the public in
4th June 2001. On Carmel, they put this
temple.
Here you have the temple representation.
You will see all the symbols again, the
stars and all that goes along with it.
And the Bahigh faith says the
fundamental unity of all religions is
its main aim.
And well, Tyler de Shadin says we must
get them all to accept a universal
Christ that satisfies them all. The
independent investigation of truth, the
equality of men and women, the
elimination of prejudice, universal
education, establishment of
international auxiliary language,
spiritual solutions to economic
problems, the harmony of science and
religion, attainment of world peace
through international cooperation. So
powerful is the light of unity that it
can illuminate. I hate these words.
totally allergic to these occult words,
the whole world.
Right? So they want to get all the
religions together under one star and uh
that star is definitely not my god. The
golden dawn, Israel, there you have the
symbol of the new age, part of the new
age, his mystic revelations, the
teachings of the Christ, two pillars,
Yahim, Boaz. Then came Taurus the bull,
Aries the ram, Buddha, Sri Krishna,
Sankara Shiva, we have the age of piscus
which brought us the Christ and then
eventually we will go to the universal
Christ. This is new age theology and it
starts of course with Yakim and Boaz
which is the very heart and soul of
Freemasonry. Again, Freemasonry controls
all these things. the musical hair. When
the moon is in the seventh house and
Jupiter aligns with Mars, then peace
will guide the planets and love will
steer the stars. This is the dawning of
the age of Aquarius. Harmony and
understanding, sympathy and trust
abounding. No more falsehood or
division. Golden living dreams of
vision. Mystical crystal revelation and
the mind's true liberation. Aquarius.
Aquarius. Aquarius. The old people will
remember that tune, won't they?
>> Yes. What a lie. Everything about this
is Luciferian. It's the coming together
in unity under occult symbols just as
Freemasonry does the same thing with its
Yahim and Boaz symbols. The Bible
doesn't talk about pillars in that
sense. Here is the patience of the
saints. Here are the ones who keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. Revelation 14:12. Those are
pillars that we can put our faith on. I
think that is the only thing. So the new
age is full of amulets and cosmic keys
and pyramid power and astrology,
natural healing, hands of light. It's
all very esoteric and very pleasing to
the mind. This wisdom, this ancient
wisdom, the Enochian workbook, arch
types of the tree of life. By the way,
the Enochian workbook is of course
apocryphal, which Roman Catholicism
teaches perfectly acceptable.
Taro, magic, allseeing eyes, pentagrams,
witchcraft, either good witchcraft, dark
witchcraft. Do you know that in England
you can take a degree at the university
in witchcraft and the government pays
for it? It's nice. You can become a
witch and you can choose to become a
dark witch or a good witch, white little
witch or a black little witch. Doesn't
really matter.
Once within the magic circle, the witch
says the following word. Great masters
of the universe, swiftly execute my
wishes, I summon you by the great names
full of power of the illuminati of the
firmament. This is calling Lucifer.
Appear to me as I evoke the sacred
influence of all the principalities and
powers. I thought we battle against
them. Here they invite them. Do you come
in peace through the power of the
exalted Illuminati?
Will you serve me and reveal all things
unto me of land and sea, of knowledge
and wisdom, of good and bad, of natural
law and of sorcery?
That's what witchcraft is about. Can you
see the language of Eden in there? Yes
or no? Yes. good and evil and all these
things. The Bible says in Deuteronomy
18:10, "There shall not be found amongst
you. Anyone that makes his son or his
daughter pass through the fire, or that
uses divine nation, or an observer of
times, or an enchanter, a witch, a
charmer, a consulter of familiar
spirits, a wizard, or a necromancer, one
who speaks with the dead.
For all that do these things are an
abomination unto the Lord. And because
of these abominations, the Lord thy God
does drive them out from before thee.
Today, the world, this is what it's
about. This is the world. Voices from
heaven, arch types of the zodiac. Now,
let's have a look at some of these great
modern channels that communicate with
the spirits. Uh the channel Virginia,
she says Jesus speaks through her. He
says death is the creation of humanity,
not of God. This is the simple truth.
Again, they teach there is no death.
Here is a new age book, the life of
death. Here's another one by Yan Kuri.
You cannot die. Then it has the symbol
of Shamash over there. You cannot die.
Is this serpent language or God
language? Sure, it's serpent language.
Ecclesiastes 9:5-6. For the living know
that they shall die, but the dead know
not anything. Neither have they anymore
a reward, for the memory of them is
forgotten. Also their love, their
hatred, their envy is now perished.
Neither have they any more portion
forever in anything that is done under
the sun. Ecclesiastic 9:6. When you're
dead, your mind ceases.
But not these people, they talk to them.
Living tarot, spiritualism, personal
alchemy. The rose is a symbol of
Lucifer, ancient magic and the new age.
They use the same symbols. They use
pillars. There is the half moon with a
star in it or the sun in it. That's the
same as the birth of the son god and his
death. And if it's in the form of the
host, then it's the eucharist if you
like. They have the face of Apollo
instead of Mary. It's just the male
form. It's exactly the same thing. So,
sun, moon, stars, Isis horror set
worship. Another channel is Jay-Z Knight
from New York. She's probably the most
famous channel in the world today.
She talks to a spirit called Rama. She
has all the famous film stars as her
clients. There she is. She's a very
pretty woman.
And uh this is by the way Masonic, but
never mind. There is her symbolism.
And you'll see that it's triangular and
all these things. Rama channeled by
Jay-Z Knight. Throughout history, we
have tried many different avenues to
remind you of your greatness, your
power, and the foreverness of your life.
We have been king, conqueror, crucified,
Christ, teacher, friend, philosopher,
anything that would permit knowledge to
occur. At times, we have intervened in
your affairs to keep you from
annihilating yourself so that life here
would continue to provide a playground
for your experiences and your evolution
into joy.
Nice. Remember that Mormons also teach
that man sinned so that we could have
joy.
This is Jay-Z Knight. We'll turn the
sound down. I'll just show you a brief
uh picture of her of her talking because
the sound is not very good. Here she
explains how she met Ranta
and she said Ranta appeared to her as
glittering light as someone who takes a
handful of glitter and throws it into a
sunray. And she looked at him and he
says she said to him, "Who are you? You
are so beautiful." And he said, "I am
Rama. I've come to help you over the
ditch."
Fascinating.
So
here is an interesting one. Let's her
let her talk for herself. The sound is
not very good but listen to what she
says.
>> We cannot become near to God in giving
our power away to a concept that there
was only one son of God. For it begs the
question then who are you?
All right. We cannot give ourselves over
to the concept that there is only one
son of God because it begs the question
then who are you? What does that imply
that you are also God? Okay,
let's ask her now to tell us what her
true faith is. Let's listen to what she
has to say. Listen carefully.
>> What is the good news?
The good news is the thing [music] that
the church holds blasphemous.
>> That the only way we can explain common
people to be divine as if they [music]
were God. And it's the one teaching they
forbade anyone to have.
[music and singing] There is only one
place
that God is explained [music]
in its most extraordinary and simple
concept and that isn't [music] the
church. It happens to be the nemesis of
the church. It's called science.
Then comes a big lot of rock and what
have you. So what don't they want you to
know? That you are God. The church does
not want you to know that you are God.
But the nemesis of the church is going
to be science. Fortunately, science is
going to destroy the church. Is science
doing a good job of that? Very good job.
False science so-called
amazing teachings. So sometimes you have
to have a little bit of help to go to
the other side. So they use drugs. Here
are uh smart drinks. This one is called
fallen angel. It's sold in a packet of
100% G's no Jesus. And you can perk up
your spiritual life by using ecstasy.
And if you have been on ecstasy and you
take a smart drink, a normal one,
whatever it is,
uh do you have Red Bull here? gives you
wings and all these drinks with a high
caffeine just that can trigger it again
and give you another trip.
The new age also teaches us how to
become divine and controls others in the
business world breakthrough performance.
Here is a young man walking over the
colds which the Bible forbids which is
also done in Hinduism which teaches you
to become divine and achieve results
through focused attention. And you can
look at someone and make him do whatever
it is you want him to do. One of these
young men came to me and he says, "I can
make you do anything I want you to do."
And I said to him, "You can make me do
nothing that my God will not permit."
Helen Shookman, she started hearing an
inaudible voice which dictated messages
to her. This continued seven years. She
wrote the course in miracles. Three
startling months preceded the actual
writing. So there she goes. She writes
the book, "Why me? Because you wish to
know the true me are willing to serve
and have given me permission to enter
your life." And so the messages went on.
And then finally she wrote what the
spirit dictated to her. Jesus Christ,
what's her first statement? There is no
need for help to enter heaven for you
have never left.
Can you see the total onslaught on the
divinity and vicarious death of Jesus
Christ and him as the only savior? This
is a total onslaught. And then come the
various chants where you say I'm not a
body. I am free for I am still as God
created me. In other words, this eternal
life aspect, the course is the beginning
and not the end. And when you go through
this course, pain is my own idea idea.
It is not the thought of God. I call
upon God's name and my own. This is
blasphemy of the highest degree. There
is no death, she writes, because the son
of God is like his father. You know,
they give all these pathetic reasons.
It's not even logic. Nothing you can do
can change eternal love. Forget your
dreams of sin and guilts.
But what does the Bible say? It's
because of sin that Jesus had to come
and die for us. Is that right? Yes. So
if we are to forget those things because
there is no death. Well then you can
carry on as you did before. Scientology
teaches you to become clear. All it is
is a scientific way of new age. You
attach yourself to Emeters, lie
detectors and they go into all your most
personal details and eventually you end
up
going when you lie about something and
so they clear you. It's a form of
confessional and then you are so
relieved that you float and become God's
magic and the western mind. The key note
of the new world religion is divine
approach. Draw near to him and he will
draw near to you. And there's a
hierarchy. The new world religion will
be the unifying of the great divine
approaches. All religions coming
together. So if we look at the doctrine
the new age versus the Bible, the Bible
says Jesus is the son of God. The new
age says Jesus is one of the masters.
The Bible says you are saved by grace.
The new age says you achieve godhood
through works. The Bible says Jesus is
the only way. And the new age says the
white Christ consciousness within. Bible
says Lucifer is the devil. The new age
says Lucifer is the true son of God. The
Bible says worship God. The new age says
worship the creation. Bible says man was
created. New age says physical man
evolved. Spiritual man always existed.
The Bible said God is not part of the
creation. The Bible said the new age
says it is pantheism
or panentheism. Sometimes if they want a
divine luciferal to appear to them gets
a little bit more complicated.
The Bible teaches the resurrection. The
new age teaches reincarnation.
The word is truth says the Bible. The
new age says truth is within. And the
Bible says wait for the second coming.
And the new age says wait for matraa.
Bible says turn from sin. New age says
there is no sin. Forget sin. The Bible
says become Christlike through
sanctification. The new age says
discover the power within.
Mother Terza who was a great new age
proponent says oh I hope I am
converting. I don't mean what you think.
If coming face to face with God, we
accept him through our lives, then we
are converting. We become a better
Hindu, a better Muslim, a better
Catholic, a better whatever we are. What
approach would I would I use? Well, for
me naturally, it would be Catholic. For
you, it might be Hindu. For someone
else, Buddhist. According to one's
conscience, what God is in your mind,
you must accept. Is this biblical
doctrine? Yes or no? No. This is serpent
doctrine. This is not biblical doctrine.
So a Roman Catholic priest might as well
be a Buddhist and they can they are
Buddhists. We must merge the ethical and
the practical, the political and the
priest. That's the theme of their
conferences. So the ransies and the
kernics, these are the Catholic
theologians and the church of England,
Dalai Lama, Muslims, Jews, cheeks, all
of them come together
and at the United Nations of faith they
were ready to move mountains
and they rehearsed an ecommenism
an ecommenical initiative which is
called the United Nations of Faith. But
I'll be giving a whole lecture on this
issue. Buddhism again teaches divinity
within. How to become one with the
divine and also teaches reincarnation.
In fact, Buddhism is just a sect of
Hinduism. That's all it is. Well, here
is the Dalai Lama. He is the present
llama. Of course, when he dies one day,
they need a successor, right? And they
can't wait for the llama to reincarnate
in a baby and let him grow up. They need
a leader immediately. So the next one is
already incarnated. There is the next
Dalai Lama. So the poor spirit of the
Dalai Lama must be jumping constantly
between these two. What a ridiculous
teaching. And people buy this.
And he's also of course a god king. This
is from Time magazine. The Dalai Lama
Tibet's exile god king just like the
pope is a god king. Who's he subject to
though? He's subject to the pope because
he bows down to him.
And the Vatican and Buddhism are one and
the same. A path to Nirvana. Emptying
yourself until there's nothing left of
you. Paradise promised light out of the
east. And suddenly the world is flooded
with these perverse little god men. Here
they are. Here's one of them, Avatar
Adidas Samrash. He's God, by the way.
Here he is. He only has hordes of women
floating around him.
And uh here he is photographed in 1993.
Here he enters a room. Everybody falls
flat. Suddenly the door at the front of
the communion hall opened. The most
exquisite bright being I had ever seen
entered. This was the one capital I had
been waiting for. What does he say? He
said it is not enough to pursue
realization as a relief from suffering.
Realization must be that which certainly
is not suffering. I am the avatar of
brightness. The way of adidam is not
about seeking to be relieved of
suffering. It is about happiness. It is
about being in love with me. all as a
condition of taking refuge in me are
obliged to fall in love with me.
I don't want to fall in love with that
fat little guy. Do you?
Anyway, let's not be derogatory. Some
people really believe that he's God.
This here is Amarita Amanda Mayi Amma.
Amma is a nickname. Now, you think these
people are just minor little figures
walking around? Oh, no. These are the
dignitaries of the United Nations. Here
she receives the award on the occasion
of the global peace initiative of women,
religious and spiritual leaders
in Geneva and she's the spokesman at the
United Nations. But you can worship her.
She's God. You can worship her. That's
fine. Amma's UN address. There is one
truth that shines through all creation.
Rivers and mountains, plants and
animals, the sun, moon and stars, you
and I. What is that? What's that called?
Pantheism. That's correct. All are
expressions of this one reality. It is
by assimilating the truth in our lives
and thus gaining a deeper understanding
that we discover the inherent beauty.
Beauty in this diversity where we work
together as a global family, not merely
belonging to a particular race,
religion, nation. Peace and happiness
will once again prevail. Blah blah blah
blah. Tears, division, conflict will go
away. It all sounds so nice. That's what
the world wants to hear. But it's not
biblical. Certainly not. This was the
avatar me baba. What do you notice about
their names? Bab.
What does Bob mean? Do you remember
gates? Gates. Babel. Gate to L. God.
Babel. This is Babylon in the making.
The Dalai Lama is a God man. This man is
the founder of the Har Krishna movement.
He calls himself the his divine grace.
Isn't that nice? I always have trouble
with his name. Bakshi deatami.
Whatever.
And there are some of his temples. You
can go in there. There he sits enshrined
in every temple in the world. And these
poor Hari Krishna kids run around with
their shaven heads and their music and
their flowers and worship this little
god man over here. And uh in all their
paintings you'll find 12 around one. 12
around one. Here you have 12 vestal
virgins around the one. Satan wants to
copy Jesus in everything, doesn't he?
Jesus had 12 disciples around one. There
were 12 tribes of you of Israel around
Yave. Satan is just a lousy copy of the
original. And he'll never get any better
than being a lousy copy.
Well, if you want to become a Hari
Krishna, you have to be poor. Unless
you're George Harrison or one of the
Beatles or one of that, then you can be
rich. I need your money too, you see.
Well, here was the original Sai Baba,
but he died. But relax he is
reincarnated. You can have him back. Uh
here is Swami Direendra.
all the uh the presidents, the high
officials of India, they in Indira
Gandhi, this was her personal guru uh he
was more like a like a whatever
bodybuilding god and then his holiness
Maharashi Mahes Yogi what this holiness
has to say is so unholy I'll put it on
the screen in a later lecture he has
nothing but murder in his mind
social service observed to the United
Nations day. There's the Bahigh faith.
The Bahigh faith has the largest
representation in the United Nations.
800 full-time members. That's the
largest of all the churches in the
world. Who controls them behind the
scene is of course another story. Well,
here is the founder. I find it so
fascinating that the Bif faith was
founded in 1844.
You know this date keeps cropping up.
It's such a fascinating date. And this
here is the Baha Allah linking the faith
with the Bahai faith founded by the Bab
meaning the gate. There you go. Here we
have all these gates leading to heaven.
And uh there is his son. Now this is
fortunately the reincarnation
of the Bob the original Sai Baba. And so
we have Sri Sati Sai Baba asham pafarti
and he calls himself almighty god.
This one particularly irritates me so I
really have to control myself. And here
he appears with his little flower and he
comes along with a gold car and he is at
this shrine where he has all the major
religions coming together. There have
been so many issues around this man that
are well, it's just disgusting. Let's
not even talk about him. But this man is
God. And all over the world, people
worship him. There's a German fellow
kneeling in front or sitting in front of
a shrine of Sai Baba. You know,
sometimes I've wondered what's happened
to this nation of my birth. I would like
to take these people and shake them and
say, "Have you forgotten the
reformation?
Have you forgotten what people were
willing to die for? Here I stand and I
can do no other. Jesus Christ is central
in our religion." And now they go and
take someone who looks like a I don't
know like a what a mop that's gone
static or something. And they worship
it. Isn't this crazy?
Well, who controls these religions? Look
at this. Jesuit swamies. The swamies.
Many of them are nothing other but
Jesuits. Here are the Jesuit swamies.
They dropped the the the dress diet and
customs of the local lingayats and
Belgium just districts. And there they
are as swamies. There they are as
Jesuits. They're Jesuits because in the
Jesuit religion, you become all things
to all men and you control everything
behind the scene. This one over here, he
recently died. He was Bagwan Shari
Rajnid Ashaw. There he is a god man. And
people worshiped him. He had 50
Rollsroyces
and the crowds went crazy over him. Just
listen to what they have to say about
these people.
>> I just met Bagwan and there it was. It's
nobody else than him.
>> Bagwan is my master and I love him.
>> I'm in love with him. That's the only
thing I can say.
Rolls-Royces two or three times a day
and is woripped literally adored by his
thousands of western followers. It is so
saddening to see their devotion for a
mere human being who considers himself
God and their submission to his
spiritual rules like [music] wearing his
picture around their neck continually or
wearing various shades of red always or
changing their names to Indian ones.
>> [cheering]
>> the generosity.
No one in his right mind would not know
that this is a walking talking living
God.
>> The guru is all important.
The guru is his lord, his master, his
savior, even greater than god. I was
really interested in their worship and
their veneration and their adoration and
the gifts and offerings they brought to
me. But I was certainly not interested
in their problems and their difficulties
and hardships and pains.
>> The guru followers believe that he
returns this incredible love that they
feel towards him. But in reality, he
feeds off their emotions to maintain his
own.
>> They too are seeking
the wisdom, the love that Bhagwan has to
offer. He has so much love and he gives
his love to everybody and it helps us to
to find our love in ourselves.
>> Well, here are some pictures of these.
>> Thousands of seekers, most of them from
broken or unstable families and already
emotionally wounded, [music] are
becoming victims of the gurus. Most of
the gurus that I know of in the west are
super rich. Gurus are more interested in
white disciples than in Indian disciples
largely because they get more money from
the whites.
They have acquired vast land holdings,
armed bodyguards,
and outrageous luxuries from posh hotels
to their own fleets of planes,
helicopters,
and as in Rajnish's case.
>> Well, I don't know whether you got that,
but can you see the magnitude how these
people worship these? That's just one of
them besides all the others. Ken Wilder,
a new age psychologist, says the great
goddess Kali of Inda when viewed in her
highest form as the wife of Shiva is a
perfect example of the assimilation of
the great mother image into new and
higher corpus of great goddess mythology
which serves as actual sacrifice in
awareness not substitute sacrifice in
blood. They hate Jesus. They hate him.
The fall was an evolutionary advance,
perfect growth.
Isn't that interesting?
Yes. What else do they say? By eating
from the tree of knowledge, not only did
men and women realize their already
mortal and finite state, they realized
they had to leave Eden's subconscious
and begin the actual life of true self.
They did not get thrown out of the
Garden of Eden. They grew up and walked
out. Incident. Incidentally, for this
courageous act, we have to thank Eve,
not blame her. That's the same teaching
as the Mormon teaching. Exactly the
same.
This book here is the coming of the
cosmic Christ. And the author is Matthew
Fox. Who's Matthew Fox? A Roman Catholic
priest who has become an episcopal
priest. It's interchangeable. It's
exactly the same thing. This book is
about the sacred and our response to the
re to it. Reverence the sacred what? The
sacred everything. Sacred creation,
stars, galaxies, whales, soil. What's
that?
>> Pantheism. What else does he say? What
creature dare deny that it is immortal
diamond, an original blessing and image
of the divine one? It is my experience
that only the human species dared to
deny its divinity dares to deny the
cosmic Christ same. This is a Roman
Catholic priest. If my thesis is correct
that it is time to move from the quest
for the historical Jesus to the quest
for the cosmic Christ. This would help
to diffuse the distorted religion and
pseudo mystical movement of our time
popularly known as fundamentalism and
also called Christofascism.
Well, who else said that these people
are the new fascists? Isn't that
interesting? So those that believe the
Bible are cristofascists. And if you
believe in this cosmic Christ, then you
are fine. He says, "Perhaps we need a
new ecumenical council will be
forthcoming. This one would be deeply
ecumenical and would call forth the
wisdom of all the world's religions."
Now, I don't think Matthew Fox is a
small fry. He's one of the great
thinkers in the movement. And what will
this cosmic Christ do? What will he
make? He will make us change culturally,
change our ways, will lead us to deep
sexuality. Hello.
This is interesting. And what else will
he do? The Eucharist. There's a promise
of matern maternal eros in this. This is
the old sex cult of Isis. It's sick. The
one of the main features of the new age
movement is to prepare the world for the
coming of the cosmic Christ, the
reappearance of the Christ. And of
course, the mind must be attuned to
occultism. That's where Harry Potter and
all these things come in. Notice the
hand signs of Mary Grand Prix. She's the
artist who paints for the movies and who
also painted the set for the ant and all
of that. JK Rowling is the author. Do
you know that the names used in there
are actual names of demons, real names,
and that they she uses the sublime
method of contamination, scrambling of
words. For example, one of her
characters is called Vlablatski
instead of Blavatski.
So this is occultism at its highest
level. And we are told that this has
values. This has nothing but satanic
values.
One of the most quoted supporters of the
Potter books is Christianity today. That
was Billy Graham's magazine.
And uh they say Harry and his friends
develop courage, loyalty, and
willingness to sacrifice for one
another. Not bad lessons in a
self-centered world, but they have the
symbol of Zeus on them.
Well, what does the new age wants to do?
It wants to alter the state of
consciousness, bring in dreams and
visions, astrology, divination,
spiritism, magic, spells, occult charms,
solstice, human sacrifices, sacred sex,
and serpent worship. That's basically
what they want. And how will they go
about it? Present it in a more palatable
form. Dismantle a students previous
beliefs. Blend new beliefs. Redefine
words. Rewrite history. Provide mystical
experiences. Immerse students in
enticing forms of new belief. Use target
beliefs to answer questions and demand
purity. As long as you demand purity,
everything's fine. The great initiates,
this is what they supposedly looked
like. The master Maroya, the Venetian
master, the great nine ones that came
again, the master helion, the master St.
Paul supposedly one of the
reincarnations
Serapsus which means Saraphim angelic
form Mahan and then the master Jesus
which of course was overshadowed by the
Christ pathetic all the other masters
are masters in their own right but when
it comes to Jesus he's overshadowed
isn't it interesting how they changed
the Bible to say instead of the spirit
the spirit of Jesus showing that Jesus
in the Bible was also controlled told by
someone else. Well, and then the great
master kumi lal singh and then the
matera the one that everyone is waiting
for the Christ, the Basati, the Iman Mi,
the Sri Krishna, the St. Patrick and the
world teacher. Now his agent or channel
in the world today is Benjamin Cream and
Benjamin Cream is a British artist and
longtime student of esoteric philosophy
has become the principal source of
information about the emergence of
Matraa. Born in Glasgow in 1922,
Benjamin Cream began studying art at an
early age and he became accomplished
painter and modernist style. His web
page if you like uh is very very
interesting. Share International is the
name and of course it has many many
links to white Catholic sites. This is
just another Jesuit as far as I'm
concerned. Benjamin Cream Reappearance
of the Christ and the modern masters of
wisdom 1982 his Tara center organization
uh took a full page advertise
advertisement and said Christ is now
here and he says revitalized Christian
churches
as well as Masonic lodges will be used
for purposes of giving mass planetary
initiation. So the churches will work
together. Share with your brothers this
joyful expectation and tell them Matraa
their friend, their brother and teacher
of old has come. Let's watch this video
and see what he has to say.
>> Good evening my dear friends.
Be ready to see me soon,
to follow my thoughts.
My
advent
is nigh.
The world teacher for the new age of
Aquarius is Maitria Buddha has been
living in London, England since 1977.
The Buddha 2,500 years ago made a
prophecy that at this time would come
into the world another great Buddha
Buddha like himself by name Maitraa who
would inspire humanity to create a
brilliant golden civilization based as
he put it on righteousness and truth and
that's what Matra has come to do. calms
tension between the eyebrows.
He's a member of the Asian community of
London. He lives there as an apparently
ordinary man, although those are now
around him know him as a very
exceptional man. Everything I hear, he
hears. He can teach through me. He can
he can inspire, he can heal and and so
on. So he has a kind of vehicle like a
window in the world through whom he can
work.
He told me to get a tape recorder which
I did little grunding portable and he
began to give me long dictations which I
repeated under the microphone and one
night three months after the initial
contact I heard the voice of my prayer
and he said very little was very simple.
He said I myself am coming. It will be
the most extraordinary evolutionary step
which humanity will take. We can either
accept the principle of sharing or else
destroy life. The the tensions inherent
in the discrepancy in living standards
between the developed world and the
third world are such as they have within
them the seeds of a third world war.
That would be nuclear and would destroy
all life human and subhuman. But we have
to make the choice. We have to invite
him. We have to invite him forward and
to come onto the radio and television
networks of the world. And on the day of
declaration, it will be the most
extraordinary experience for humanity.
We will see his face on the television
screens wherever you have access to
television. But he won't speak. He won't
say anything. But his thoughts and his
ideas will enter telepathically into the
minds of all humanity. He will come into
mental telepathic contact with the whole
of humanity simultaneously.
>> See the light
which
beckons you into the future
or sound forever
the nail of regret.
>> Don't you hate that type of voice?
See the light that beckons you into the
future or forever sound the nail of
regret.
How pathetic, isn't it? He's going to
appear on all the television screens,
communicate telepathically with
everyone, and everybody will know that
they have to rally around him or else.
and the principle of sharing,
redistribution of wealth will be
accepted. All these things we've been
speaking about. This is nothing other
than plain Roman Catholicism
being taught in a new age form. The
reappearance of the mis the masters of
wisdom. Matraea's mission all these
things. In 1977
they he was asked have you anything to
say about the holy father in Rome and he
says the master of Jesus will take over
the throne of St. Peter in Rome. This
event is now imminent. Then he said in
1979, the decease of Pope Paul V 6 and
the sudden death of Pope John Paul one
month after as month later as Pontiff
makes it more than likely that the
present Pope John Paul 2 will be the
last. Same as the Marian equivalents.
Message number 53. He says the law of
God I am I am. and his priorities.
Established peace, inauguration of a
system of sharing, removal of guilt and
fear, education of mankind, introduction
of the mysteries, beautifification of
all cities, removal of all barriers of
travel, and creation of a pool of
knowledge accessible to all. Sounds so
nice. Adequate supply of food, adequate
housing. Of course, he doesn't say there
that this housing will have to be
shared. health care and education,
achieving maintaining e ecological
balance, social political justice for
all. And he says that the God in man
shines forth within you all sits a
divine being. Is this God language or
serpent language? He speaks like the
devil. What else does he say? Theology
is usually useless and argument over
scripture is wasteful energy. Simply
take the theme of loving and live it.
Live it. doesn't like the Bible. That's
for sure.
He says, "I asked you to accept this new
level of understanding. If you cling to
every phrase of the Bible and argue its
interpretation, you miss the point of
God's message." Think of this force. The
force be with you. He talks about the
facts of the Christ, the facts of the
hierarchy, very tight time scheduled.
Time between now and the reappearance of
the Christ is short. Learn the great
invocation. No, Satan is saying, "I'm
coming soon.
But when we say Jesus says I'm coming
soon, then the world says what? Oh no,
not for a long time.
There's the great invocation. I will not
read this silly little prayer of theirs.
Without sharing, there can be no
justice. Without justice, there can be
no peace. Without peace, there can be no
future. And then mysterious crosses
started appearing in the sky. And then
suddenly he appeared one day. Well,
there he was in 1988. Who was there to
film him? CNN.
Of course, the owners of CNN, Ted
Turner, was a 33 degree Freemason. So,
who would expect anyone else to
photograph him? And there he appeared.
That is his symbol. That is his symbol.
It's totally our cult. You've got the
swastikas. You've got the the uh star
and the moon and the crosses and the
unification of all the religions. As he
appeared in 1988, he healed all the
people. He had the hissop in his hand
and thousands bowed down before him and
worshiped him as God. And then CNN says
he disappeared into the sky like a
mystic. Then he appeared on television.
Television screens switched themselves
on in the United States in some areas
and in Australia.
Jesus stars on American television.
Hundreds of TV viewers claimed to have
seen him. His 1998 appearances were in
Cyprus, Iceland, Argentina, Russia,
Mexico, all over the world, Austria,
Canada. Whoa, did you know that? March
1st in Toronto, Blanca, Melo, Oregon,
USA. His 1999 appearances in Croatia
where he appeared to 100 people,
Christians in that case, in China, to
Muslims, in Poland to Christians. Then
to Muslims, fundamentalist Christians,
500 saw him, 150, 150. There you go. the
numbers of all that saw him. Turkey
appeared to Christians in Morocco to
Muslims. In 2001, he appeared in
Argentina, Brazil, India, Poland, China,
New Zealand, Pentagon. Do you know about
all these things? All these appearances
in Mexico appeared in a stadium and
35,000 people bowed down and worshiped
him as Jesus Christ.
Interesting.
150 400 150 200. Then in 2002 he
appeared in Paraguay on the 24th of
December to 200 Christians and Share
International has no information on
appearances after this date. The second
coming of Christ we will deal with this
is supposed to be says the Bible with
power and great glory and it'll be
coming in the clouds to punish those who
refuse to know God to redeem God's
people. He comes with his angels like
lightning that shines from the east to
the west. All eyes will see him. There
will be a resurrection. Jesus will come
and every eye will see him, says the
Bible. He won't appear on television and
speak to you through mind control.
There's no such thing in the Bible. This
is the false one who will come, but
Jesus Christ will come with the clouds
of heaven. All eyes will see him.
Revelation 1 verse 7. Revelation 22:20.
He which testifies these things says,
"Surely I come quickly. Amen. Even so,
come Lord Jesus." I hope that the world
can be warned not to be duped into
believing in these false messiahs, these
false teachers who set them upelves up
as gods while they live the most
lentious lives on this planet. while
they live in luxury and splendor and
then propagate all these things. I hope
the world can be warned to realize that
the Bible is their only hope.
[clears throat] This total onslaught on
Jesus Christ and him as savior must be
exposed. And may God help us to do it.
Amen.
la.
Hey, hey, hey.
[music]
Happy birthday.
Oh,
thank you.
oh, glory.
Oh
god.
Oh,
hey.